[Music]
Most of them will recover if this treatment is given to them,
but unfortunately the area, the hospital, and the place
are basically healthy in the materials consumed.
These people survived the rescue of a guardian from the earthquake. If
this material is not available, there will be victims in addition to the
victims that have been declared
[Music]
[Music] A bigger,
bigger disaster.  Due to the capacity of the
press sector in northwest Syria, the most difficult hours
were the first 24 hours. All of our health facilities, including
hospitals and centers, were full of patients, and a large number
of patients were placed in the corridors on the ground.
[Music]
From the dust, nothing could be seen, and
people were constantly on the phones as if they could see that there was someone on the ground.
I found this Assi with her feet under the stairs. The
second shock happened. The staircase remained standing.
People caught me. The next shock happened. What I did to her and I was blown away.
[Music] We are still in need of
aid. We have contacted all UN
agencies and the
World Health Organization. We have sent
the needs, but so far very little has arrived.
The situation is still out of control, and
most of them are still full of patients to provide medical services